قصر الحسينيه حيث حيث الاحتفال الرئيسي
وحفل الاستقبال ايضا بعد وبعدها مباشره
سيخرج
الامير ضمن الموكب الاحمر كما تحدثنا
وسيكون هناك يعني ترتيبات ايضا داخل قصر
الحسينيه حيث سيكون هناك في الاستقبال
الحمد لله
الامريكي
بايدن الى مقر حفل الزفاف استقبلوها الان
العهد الاردني او زوجه الرئيس الامريكي
يستخبرها الان الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني والملك رانيا اتفضل
نعم يعني هي وصلت يوم امس وهناك عدد من
الزعماء مثل يعني من اكد حضوره مثل الرئيس
العراقي بالاضافه الى الرئيس الماليزي
وهناك عدد من الشخصيات
المسؤولين وبعض الامراء من الدول العربيه
وايضا من الدول الاوروبيه مثل مثلا
الامير امير ويلز الامير ويليام وزوجته
ايضا يعني هناك ولا زالت مطار عمان يستقبل
الضيوف في في المطار ومن ثم يذهبون مباشره
الى حفل الاستقبال في في منطقه او في
مدينه في قصر الحزينيه في منطقه دابوق
هناك يعني هذه هناك اجراءات امنيه في كافه
الشوارع الاردنيه للحفاظ على تامين وصول
كافه الوفود الى منطقه الى قص ر الحسينيه
بالاضافه الى اغلاق الشوارع من هنا من
منطقه الزهران من جبل عمان لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات